hey this is fresh towel Walker here's a
fun game you can play with another
person
the game starts on January 1 you and the
other person take turns
naming dates but there's a restriction
the date you call out must be later in
the year and have either the same month
value or the same day value as the
previous date that was called out so for
example the game starts on January 1 the
first player can either name a date
that's later in January or the first
player can name one of the future months
but have the same day value as one now
whichever date the first player calls
out the second player has to abide by
the same restriction of calling out
dates you and the other player keep
calling out dates and the player to call
out December 31 wins the game I'm going
to tell you that one of the players can
always win this game the question is
which player is it and what is the
winning strategy as a bonus doesn't
matter if this game is played in a leap
year give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution
so there is a simple procedure that the
first player can always guarantee a win
the first player should call out dates
that are in the following list written
in the format month / day these are a
list of 12 dates they can be remembered
because the day value is equal to the
month value plus 19 so the first player
can always call out one of these dates
and continue to call out another date in
this list until the first player gets to
the winning date of December 31 so let's
see how this plays out the game starts
on January 1 the first player thinks
about which date could the first player
call out and clearly there's another day
in this list which works so that's
January 20th
so the first player says I'm going to
call out January 20th now the second
player can either call out another later
day in January or can call out another
month with the day value of 20 so let's
suppose a second player calls out
another day in January and calls out
January 28th so the first player thinks
all right how can I get to the next
winning date scanning this list you can
see that you can call out another month
with the day value of 28 and that would
be September 28th so the first player
calls out 928 and now the second player
has to either choose a day that's later
in September or goes ahead and calls a
future month with the same day value so
let's say the second player calls out
another month and says November 28th so
the first player says all right from
November 28th I can call out the next
winning date which is November 30th now
you can see the second player stuck from
November 30th there is no later date in
November so the second player has to
call out to something in December and
that would be December 30th and that
leaves the first player
the winning date of December 31 so this
is an example of how the first player
can win the game now there different
ways that the game can be played but it
will always end with the first player
being able to call up December 31 so as
long as you start out by naming January
20th and then continuing to name one of
the dates in this list you will always
be able to win this game so this is a
strategy for how the game can be won but
the question is how are we able to
derive this you want to be able to think
backwards so by rule December 31 is a
winning date so logically this means if
you name out any other day that's in
December that's going to be a losing
date because if you name out another day
that's in December that gives your
opponent the chance to name out December
31 so you don't want to be calling out a
losing date so what's the next date
which is not losing
well you jump back to November and you
think about November 30th this turns out
to be a winning date because it forces
the next player to play to have to play
the losing date of December 30th there's
just no other choice for what the other
player can do so we can deduce that
November 30th is a winning date now by
similar logic all of the other days that
are earlier in the month of November
have to be losing if you called out
November 5th that would give your
opponent the chance to call out November
30th so you don't want to do that those
are all losing dates and even thinking
back once one more month this would also
mean that October 30th is also losing
date because if you name out October
30th your opponent will then name out
November 30th and that will put you in a
losing position but what about one day
before that well we can deduce that
October 29th is therefore a winning date
this forces the if you can name the
state the next player will be forced to
play one of the losing dates
any of the later dates in October will
be losing and any of the November 29th
or December 29th are also losing dates
so we can say October 29th is a winning
date and we see a pattern here to get
the next winning date we want to go one
month back in one day back
so we subtracted one from the month
value and the day value and we can keep
generating the other winning dates and
we keep doing that all the way until the
beginning January and that'll get us to
January 20th is the first winning date
and this is the pattern of the day is
equal to month plus 19 because it's true
for December 31 and each time we're
decreasing the day in the month value by
one so these are the lists of winning
dates and it doesn't matter if it's a
leap year or not because you can always
name out these dates whether you have an
extra day in February or not did you
figure out this problem thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Walker and if you like this video please
check out my books there are links in
the video description